[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Andy Staples covers college football for
the athletic he's the host of The Andy
Staples show he joins us on the program
Andy thanks for joining us assess the
current rankings and could any do you
expect anything to happen this weekend
that could change the top four
potential Central Shenanigans this
weekend potential Shenanigans because
USC UCLA feels like a very close game
Vegas think it's going to be a close
game it's I think UFC's a one and a half
Point favorite neither defense looks
capable of stopping either offense so I
think it's gonna be fun and then TCU
playing Baylor in Waco
Baylor very up and down over the last
few weeks like if you get good Baylor
and good Blake shape in their
quarterback this is gonna be a really
tight game if you get the Baylor team
that played K-State last week TCU is
going to roll and so that's an
interesting one because you know we
could see those two teams
be in a very different place next week
because USC obviously they lose they
would be out of playoff contention I'm
still not convinced TCU would be out I
think a 12-1 big 12 champ TCU given How
Deep The Big 12 was and how there's
really no weeks off in that League I
think they have to get some
consideration now if they're 13-0
they're in and this is one of their
toughest challenges left so we'll see
what happens if I said Tennessee has one
loss to end the regular season and tcu's
undefeated
two seasons
no okay it's a choice it would but it
wouldn't be a choice between those two I
don't think I think then you're talking
about Tennessee versus maybe a 12 in one
USC Pac-12 champ or the the loser of the
Ohio State Michigan game and I think
that then it's a little bit different
but I I think well let's look at those
scenarios if I said I got a one-lost USC
team and a one-lost Tennessee team
who would who do you think the playoff
committee would take they're going to
take Tennessee and everybody's going to
tell you they're going to take USC I'm
telling you right now they would take
Tennessee in that situation because they
always have taken that particular type
of team in that situation because at the
the way they boil it down at the end
they like good wins and Tennessee would
have a couple of great wins they they
have the the LSU win in Baton Rouge
where they won 40-13 they're winning
against Alabama
USC would have the wins that they would
be getting over the next three weeks
UCLA
Notre Dame and then probably Oregon or
Utah in the Pac-12 championship game
and those you know those are good sets
of good wins in in both cases but then
the when they get to that point they say
they're supposed to break the tie with
conference Champion or not they never do
that they've never done that in the past
when they do it for the first time it
will be the first time what they do is
they decide who's a better team who they
think would win if they played and like
if you ask a guy in Vegas right now if
you said what what is the line
on a neutral site Tennessee USC game
Tennessee by seven and a half or eight
so they'll pick Tennessee this I've I've
had this this idea over the past few
years like if you have to decide between
four and five I think the committee
should be allowed to kidnap the head
coach of the number one team like roll
up in a windowless van grab Kirby Smart
and Athens put a bag over his head bring
him to an undisclosed location you shoot
him up with true serum and in this case
you go Kirby
who do you want Tennessee or USC who
would you rather play and he'll go give
me the Trojans and you go okay you get
the balls that would be good TV Andy by
the way tremendous first Magnus get get
on this yes okay if I said a one lost
Tennessee team against the one loss
either Ohio State or Michigan team
uh-huh now if you have my Kirby Smart
kidnap scenario
and the and and Ohio State is the team
that hasn't has narrowly lost the
Michigan Ohio State game
Kirby might say give me the Vols well
so that that's the interesting I think
Ohio state has a better chance of
getting in if they lose that game than
Michigan does if they lose that game
because Ohio state has that Notre Dame
win they are viewed as probably the the
more complete team that you know they
could throw they could run unless
they're playing Northwestern and they
can't seem to do either but they're much
better defensively what's weird about
this is I if I had to pick that game
today and obviously we'll all be picking
it next week I'd pick Michigan to win
that game I just feel like Michigan's
been more consistent I feel like the way
Michigan plays is not a great matchup
for Ohio State but it would be a
terrible matchup for Michigan against
the Georgia for example I think Ohio
State's probably a better matchup
against the Georgia just because they
can do some different things but you
know that that's just gonna have to
shake out I I do think if if Michigan
wins that game that's the better chance
for the Big Ten to get two in
if I said if we're going with who would
be favored by Vegas if I said Tennessee
was going to play TCU neutral site right
now right now Tennessee is going to be
favored
Tennessee is going to be favored but I
don't know I don't know by how much
because you know we've seen Tennessee
against Georgia where when that offense
doesn't work what do you got and we've
seen TCU place and do what TCU does
that's different from say USC like USC
wins one way they score a bunch of
points their defense occasionally gives
up a bunch of points but they score a
bunch of points and they win North
Carolina is the same thing
Michigan kind of wins the same way every
time TCU has been capable of winning
different ways they can win the shootout
and they can win in a rock fight and
George is really the only other team
we're talking about in here that's
proven they can do that like Tennessee
hasn't proven they can win in a
different way so that's where I I'd like
to I like TCU and I also like the fact
that CCU has really in in conference
play had no weeks off they were playing
a a decent to good team every single
time and other leagues have kind of chum
at the bottom where you have a week that
you can sleep walk through and still win
tcu's had to be on edge every single
week now if they lose to Baylor and the
committee drops them below Tennessee and
they're probably never coming back but I
I still think they should get
consideration for that because the Big
12 has been so deep this year how up for
grabs is the Heisman
very very I did a blind resume thing
last week with the quarterbacks and the
running backs and I threw Jalen Carter
in there from Georgia the defensive
tackle because I think there's a real
good chance he's actually the best
player in the country but if you look at
the quarterbacks and I think this will
be a quarterback year unless Blake
Quorum just blows up against Ohio State
uh they're they're producing at really
similar rates I mean it depends on what
stat you like the most are your yards
per tenth person are you a touchdowns
produced person but you know it's CJ
Stroud from Ohio State Drake made from
North Carolina bonex from Morgan Caleb
Williams from USC Mac Duggan from TCU
hen and hooker from Tennessee they're
all in that mix and it's a matter of who
can separate Hendon hooker's not going
to get another chance where everybody's
watching unless they're losing to Bandy
or South Carolina which they don't want
to be in that situation so I think he's
he's sort of in the clubhouse he signed
his scorecard he's just waiting for
everybody else to show up Caleb Williams
from USC I think has the best chance to
really shine over a several week period
because they're playing like that
everyone's gonna be watching them
against UCLA if they win that game
everyone's watching them against Notre
Dame and then obviously CJ Stroud's like
Quorum when they play the nation's eyes
will be on that game and if one of them
just has a Legendary game real good
chance they win yeah I've been saying
Caleb Williams is the Dark Horse and
keep an eye on him because he has three
games that will be Standalone games the
UCLA is big game uh Notre Dame is always
big and then the Pac-12 I mean the USC
is not helped out by Oregon and UCLA
losing this past weekend but as far as
playing against Marquee teams Standalone
games he's got three chances where you
know CJ Stroud has got the Michigan game
uh correct and maybe the Big Ten
Championship but that's probably going
to be against the very over matched West
team so yeah and Drake May I'm telling
you guys watch Drake May he's got more
touchdown passes than CJ Stroud he leads
North Carolina in rushing he may really
be the best player in the country and
the thing about Drake May and Caleb
Williams I think they're in very similar
situations their defenses have been not
good this season I I'm probably just bad
bad's probably the right word they've
been under so much pressure to score
every time they get the ball and they've
generally done that and I think that's
pretty amazing so I do do yourself a
favor watch a little Drake may I think
oh no I have but I'm telling the
audience but Black Friday North Carolina
NC State that they'll be kind of stand
alone give yourself a chance to watch
him play he's fun as I told this
audience a couple of weeks ago that
there's going to be teams that will tank
for a quarterback in 2024 and it's Drake
May and this was according to Caleb huh
or Kayla Williams well from the Scout
that uh is a great resource to me uh NFL
scouty said Drake May is is the
quarterback uh and he said that teams
will tank for Drake May in 2024. I mean
I might tank for Drake May right now
like he came on our show last week and
this is a man who oozes confidence you
you know that that this guy is in charge
and it's interesting he was committed to
Alabama first he's the brother of Luke
May who played basketball at North
Carolina and was it was a big star there
on on the basketball court and he he
needed Sam Howell to show that you could
be successful at quarterback in North
Carolina to decide okay I'll do this
instead of Alabama because I really want
to go to North Carolina and I mean they
are they're potentially going to be a
12-1 ACC champ if they can beat Clemson
and that is not something I would have
predicted at the beginning of the year
Andy always great to talk to you thanks
for uh giving us all that information
thank you Dan that's Andy Staples host
of the coincidentally Andy Staples show
covers college football for the athletic